the corona virus pandemic threatens a
worldwide wave of sickness but it's the
healthiest thing to happen to government
power in a very long time it'll leave
the state with a rosy glow but our
freedom will end up more Haggard than
ever for the sake of their survival all
animals experience fear human beings
perhaps most of all wrote economic
historian Robert Higgs his 1987 book
crisis and Leviathan examines how bad
times caused governments to grow in
scope and power the people who have the
effrontery to rule us who call
themselves our government understand
this basic fact of human nature they
exploit it and they cultivate it whether
they compose a warfare state or a
welfare state
they depend on it to secure popular
submission compliance with official
dictates and on some occasions
affirmative cooperation with the state's
enterprises and adventures or as rahm
emanuel put it in 2008 you never want a
serious crisis to go to waste and what i
mean by that is an opportunity to do
things you think you could not do before
the federal reserve has become the
default doctor for whatever ails the US
economy noted a skeptical Wall Street
Journal editorial board but economic
fallout from the virus relates mainly to
the damage to global supply chains and
expected limits on travel and commerce
as the world tries to mitigate the rates
of infection nobody is going to take
that flight to Tokyo because the Fed is
suddenly paying less on excess reserves
and will stimulus spending repair
disrupted supply chains and put
production lines back into operation a
minute sooner than demand for goods and
services dictates not a chance
public health has long been a playing
field for fear and calculation giving us
intrusive laws that sit on the books
waiting to be invoked by the next
microorganism to catch the public's
attention those laws include a nearly
unlimited power to quarantine people
suspected of exposure to infectious
diseases coronavirus will leave behind a
residue of laws spending and precedents
for future government actions that's
because of what Higgs calls the ratchet
effect by which the aftermath of each
crisis sees government shrink a little
but never back to its pre-crisis status
thus crisis typically has produced not
a temporarily bigger government but also
permanently bigger government he wrote
so even after the public panic retreats
the politicians calculations subside and
coronavirus becomes more knowable and
treatable we'll be left with the
permanent swelling of government caused
by this latest crisis
[Music]